[Music]
hello and welcome to the friendship
onion hello that's my friend domonick
manakanen monahan yes actually i
actually got that wrong that's all right
it happens with everyone that's weird i
told you i'm thinking of dropping the g
don't really that's why i got it wrong
okay
um yes we're here now guys we do have a
special guest this week a little um
comment to make here
is that because he was such a fantastic
guest we did not want to lose our
fantastic guests we only had one day one
day we couldn't get them here today i
was on an unexpected travel day it kind
of came out of nowhere
so billy conducted the interview and can
i say yeah it was like watching david
frost you can see that like an early
david letterman oh you can incredible
stuff well it does help that he's a
fantastic guest yeah fantastic guest
fantastic interview but before we jump
into that should we should we just uh
answer a couple of questions
peeling the onions
how much fun are you
to keep our house so clean and true
what you looking for you looking for
stuff i was looking for the script oh
yeah okay well i'll just read you the
questions
this is from aurora in location unknown
what a lovely name yeah a cool place to
live as well she says um what is the
scariest or most terrifying film you
have seen and please can you give us a
little bit of details about that thing
i'll tell you don guam the brood
b-r-double od yes the brood 1980s
imagine if you will cran hill glasgow
scotland terrifying
is this the film no no
this is my life this is your life it's
terrifying i'm there with my friends
we're watching all these horror movies
over here
wow see let's see
14.
let's say 14.
and uh we'd watch you know rabid
piranha
scanners oh scanners where his head
explodes all these 80s you know horror
movies and i went to my friend's house
david arbuckle hi dave
and he lived at the bottom of the hill i
loved the top
and me and my friends watched this movie
the brood is it about a chicken in a bad
mood it's eggs
no it's a woman she's got brood and
she's got like a womb outside her body
and she gives birth to these like
monster things that then she uses as her
brood she she's happy about it she's
happy that she's giving birth to
monsters i think she loves it yes i
remember it and oh my god it gave me the
fear see that walk up the hill after we
watched
it i didn't sleep down dark alleyways
the bridge windows the face is looking
at
the brood
it's kind of when it catches you at the
at the right time in your life right
because
give us a dom which well mine
oh god but there's good stories with
both i'll be very brief with both see
when you said 14 and you're
impressionable and all that kind of
stuff mine at 14 was the original
nightmare in elm street
and we saw freddy krueger a couple of
weeks ago at the convention and i told
you i went hiya robert because his
actual name's robert you've seen him
before and you've seen him before he
didn't wave no no no he went like this
and i said to you you just did the
freddy hand to me
so people go all right freddie and he
goes
so that when i was a kid that scared me
no wonder he's in your dreams very
sophisticated isn't it because you watch
horror films at night and then you go to
sleep at night and then you're not
supposed to sleep in the film but you
want to go to sleep because it's late
and then you get scared tired you know
what i mean so that
but when i've watched it now it seems a
little bit silly the first movie that
johnny depp was in by the way which is
interesting that was his that was his
film debut was it really yeah
did he get sucked through the bed got
sucked through the bed yeah terrifying
all that blood on the on the ceiling
must have left the right mess for the
maids
but
objectively
the film that really gave me the
heebie-jeebies was have you seen a film
called martyrs
no
i wouldn't recommend it tell me about it
well
it's
it seems that these
youngsters
have been imprisoned by this
nefarious kind of gentleman and he's
taken all their skin off how far i don't
know from head to toe they've not got
skin on them but they're kept alive
through some sort of
medical
iv drips and syringes and stuff but i
just remember a friend of mine said you
have to watch this film and i think he
said it to kind of like see if i could
watch it
and i did watch it but there's a moment
where the before
our heroine
has had all of her skin taken clean off
she walks into a room
and
does not expect to see
a captive person in there right with all
of their skin off completely off and the
captive person says something along the
lines of don't stay here he'll take all
your skin off and then she realizes that
guy is going to take all her skin off
and he does
take all her skin off it's an awful film
what is were you when you watched i was
pretty old i would say 28 29. is it
italian
what made you think it was italian
idea yeah where did that come from i
think taking skin off tomatoes did they
not like the skin and tomatoes in their
sauce or something didn't didn't
italians make like some horror movies oh
did they what was it
what a scary italian film no
what was there what was this film called
no no
who made it what country oh i don't know
i don't know was it in english ah it's
been a long time since i've seen it i'm
going to say it was in english i don't
remember subtitles i was too busy
looking at the fact that i mean can you
imagine no
it's hard to imagine what a human body
looks like alive with all its skin i'll
never watch that film it's terrifying i
don't want to watch it so that's the
scary one okay well thanks sir and then
shall i read this question since you
yeah i don't have the thing yeah yeah
finally before we jump into our
incredible cast oh yeah and i must say
the incredible interviewer
we have lauren
from chicago to win this city buddy
city of big shoulders broken dreams yeah
who's 22 she put a name there she's her
age there she's 22. she said what
ungodly thing was in eowyn soup now
there is a story behind this isn't there
that
supposedly and we'd have to get it from
pete jackson
uh to corroborate this but i'm pretty
sure it's true because i think pete said
it in the
dvd extras
they were on location right out in the
middle of nowhere struggling
for a meal and i think the caterers just
said look we're gonna struggle today
because it's snowing and we can't get to
generators and all this kind of stuff
we'll bring you a soup yeah and
supposedly the soup was so poor
that pete said let's
use that as a story beat and we'll have
eowyn having made that soup for
aragon is that true supposedly that is
the story behind the ungodly soup so i
think it was uh that's only in the
extended version right
i really like it because
i think well they're both brilliant but
it's nice to see aragon in a late moment
of you know moment of brevity yeah i
thought that was really nice yeah he has
it kind of catch on his lip yeah and
he's kind of like oh my god this is
awful
thank you lauren for that question now
should we bring on i guess why don't you
introduce him because um
you did the interview
you over there
talking to you i would um i would
absolutely love that you'll probably
remember him from such programs as
mythbusters
yes i've met him a few times he's a
lovely fella and er and obviously loves
to make things and blow things up
it's mr adam savage oh fantastic
well ladies and gentlemen here we are on
the friendship onion but dom as you know
is not here at the moment but we do have
someone who
most people would agree it's better than
joe monahan it's mr adam savage hey
[Applause] [Music]
how are you sir i am really good it's
good to see you sir uh great to see you
oh i tell you whenever we bump into each
other
i always have a lot of fun so i was
really really excited when we heard that
you could come on to the friendship
onion oh it's my delight yeah we ran
into each other at about a half dozen
cons last year yeah yeah i know and it's
it's never the right time to get
deeply into stuff and you've all you've
always got such great stories and
they always they always bring up another
question for me i i think i want to ask
adam this now and
when you're in a green room or in a cafe
or something it's not the right place
of course so um it's
really lovely to see you and uh
and thank you very much for coming on
you seem as though you're in somewhere
that would be used for creating things
adam indeed you're all right this is uh
my cave my shop uh in san francisco it's
about two blocks from my house
and this is where we do all the content
for uh my youtube channel tested oh
right cool this is the new tested yeah i
saw that how long has that been up and
running um actually now we think we're
almost uh nine years in uh is it really
nine or ten years in or even more
actually
it might even be 11 years my goodness
i'm i'm yeah time passes really quickly
at this point yeah
we're just saying that it's my
it's my son's 16th birthday today
and i was like
people have been sending photos of you
know when he was a baby and a in a pram
and you're just like oh my god where did
that 16 years go it's it's
absolutely crazy
i am my
my sons are 23
and i was thinking about how when i look
at them i still see them like
like an onion actually i see them at
every age i have known them all at once
yeah and when people say you actually
know the person when they were three
you you can see that now when i look
back i go oh yeah that was jack i can
see jack when i look in those photos but
um
it's it's amazing it's amazing how
quickly it goes
and uh that's why we have to seize every
moment which seems a thing that you do
adam i try i try by the way happy
birthday to your son right he just got
his
uh first guitar his like his guitar
because there's lots of guitars around
the house my guitars over the years and
he
picks and chooses whatever one when he's
playing
yeah but he said you know i'd love a
jazz master i'd love a
a miami blue jazz master and i was like
that is a cool guitar that is a cool
first guitar so uh he's he's absolutely
thrilled i think but if i was you i
could have built it from pieces of you
know a tree and some cat's tails and i
could have built a jazz master
it would take a while but yeah
absolutely it's very nice actually
because it brings me to i was going down
a little kind of google hole when i was
uh reading up on you yesterday and then
it said and i hope this is true it
probably isn't as those things in
internet is but they said that you
got into making things because of a a
bike shop
that you would take your bike to the
shop the guy would fix it but then he
started to show you how to fix it yeah
and then you were like oh wow i can take
this thing apart and put it back
together and it's not actually that hard
is that sort of a story no that's
absolutely exactly how it happened that
was the first time someone showed me
through a mechanical system he showed me
how to change my bike tire
and by the end of that year i was taking
bikes apart and reconfiguring them
and it was the first time i sort of was
able to put a mechanical arrangement in
my brain
and see it here as well as seeing it
here right yeah that's the information
i'm always chasing
right yeah because i i ca if i take
something apart that's it it will never
ever be together again
but in my mind i feel like oh yeah i
could i can fix this i can do it but i
can't
well i mean this is the thing with
with kids taking stuff apart is once
you've taken enough things apart you
start to actually internalize how they
go back together but until you've done
that it's i watch
videos of people like taking apart
watches and putting them back together
it's one of my favorite things on
youtube and to me it's like a magic
trick when they put all the screws in a
cup and clean them and then pour them
out and somehow put this watch back i'm
like how do you know where the screws go
i get very stressed out yeah yeah
absolutely even even uh a skateboard my
son was in his skateboarding for a while
and he said we don't need to keep buying
um
bearings you can clean them and even
that seemed like i'm taking apart a
spaceship here this isn't you know even
taking a wheel and
but i'd love to be like i'd love to be
able to kind of take things and make
things
lollipop lollipop i love to drink ollie
pop i just made that up tom because it's
my new favorite drink lollipop now
it used to be i used to like drinking
sort of sugary sodas and stuff and we
know it's not good for us so i stopped
drinking them
and uh i've just found this ollie pop
brand that are fantastic all different
flavors at the moment i'm loving orange
they also do like a traditional cola and
root beer and cherry vanilla is a
fantastic one they've got lots and lots
of flavors and they are brilliant the
big thing that's really bad about normal
sodas is the sugar so much sugar like a
normal
can of cola is like 39 grams of sugar
now you're only supposed to have 30
grams and a whole day
now with lollipop you're maybe getting
two or five grams at the very most like
the vintage cola has got two grams of
sugar all from natural sources no sugar
added it is fantastic stuff and it
tastes amazing
and they're so confident that you will
love their product that they offer a
hundred percent money-back guarantee to
orders placed through their website
receive 20 off plus free shipping on
your order i recommend trying their
variety pack this is a great way to try
all their delicious flavors go to drink
lollipop dot com slash onion or use code
onion at checkout to claim this deal
that's
d-r-i-n-k-o-l-i-p-o-p
dot com slash onion
lollipop can also be found in over 8 000
stores across the country including
kroger target whole foods sprouts and
wegmans
i've been looking for a way to offset my
carbon footprint but had no idea where
to start until i found ren ren is a
startup that's making it easy for
everyone to make a meaningful difference
in the climate crisis right now they're
focused on monthly subscriptions where
you can calculate your carbon footprint
then offset it by supporting awesome
climate projects that plant trees
protect rainforests and remove co2 from
the sky their goal is to unlock the
collective action of millions of
individuals to drive the systemic change
needed to end the climate crisis signing
up for ren is an easy way to do
something meaningful about the climate
crisis wren practices hyper transparency
once you sign up to make a monthly
contribution to offset your carbon
footprint you'll receive monthly updates
about the tree planting rainforest
protection and carbon removal projects
you're funding you can even see the
exact coordinates of the trees you
planted it's going to take all of us to
end the climate crisis do your part
today by signing up for ren go to ren
dot co slash onion sign up and they'll
plant 10 extra trees in your name that's
w-r-e-n
dot c-o slash onion start making a
difference thank you ren
the last time we were talking
we we got on to richard taylor and weta
and those guys
when we were making lot of rings that
was my
that was my favorite days when i went to
weta and i saw those guys and you know
you'd be passing you'd see someone
making a dagger
and someone else is making a a tiny
version of ministerith
do you think how how does all this
happen what is going on you know so uh
how did because i know you know these
guys how did that happen how did you get
to know the the wetter well for anyone
listening who doesn't know weta is the
um
special effects
physical uh special effects that you
know adam works with but also there's
digital wetter
but and the physical special effects
that the masks of the orcs the armor
everything that you see came from this
weta workshop and i've never asked you
how did you meet those guys or get to
know them
i had i had met richard taylor a couple
of times at san diego comic-con
and in i think
2013 i was on a i built a science stage
show with jamie heinemann and we were
touring it down
uh down in
australia and then in we came down to
auckland to perform it for a couple of
nights
and i thought oh this is my chance so we
actually my wife and i flew in to
wellington
uh and i spent and then i reached out to
richard taylor and said i'd love to come
by and he said by all means by all means
come on and him
everyone has a richard taylor impression
right
um and uh i went over to weta that
morning and spent uh i think eight hours
touring the facilities i had lunch with
peter jackson that day and that's when i
mean and that's really the day that
started uh it's the day that weta became
part of my extended family or i became
part of their extended family and it was
the beginning of my friendship with
peter uh and now ever i before covet i
was getting down to wellington two or
three times a year to film stuff and to
hang out and see those guys you know
i've stayed on richard's farm i
i just i feel like it's one of my extra
homes down there yeah they're wonderful
people huh
it really is i you know as you were
talking about all the amazing things you
see last time i was there it was um feet
as far as the eye could see hobbit feet
like sticking up as they were in
production delivering
stuff like that is just great and that
sort of that passion i remember pete
telling us
because you'll know that pete was
basically a one-man
movie set for a while and just doing
everything and he wanted to make a mask
of his head because he'd heard about
this you know a paper mache whatever
head
so that he could then
make his head and blow up on screen you
know explode it somehow but he told us
that
no one had showed him how to do it or
anything so he put on
himself
without any vaseline around him so when
he took it off it took every hair every
eyelash that was all perfectly in this
thing
um i think that so many makers have this
story because i did the same thing when
i was learning about casting materials i
did my whole chest and yeah it was it
was yeah it was like waxing it was not
pleasant the reason this came up is i
was just doing a job last week and i had
to get a cast done and they did
brilliant but exactly like you they
hadn't done here
so the thing was all off and just
hanging you know and they're trying to
put down alcohol together and those
little hairs hurt a lot oh my heart's so
bad
i'll be like i'll tell you anything you
want to know
but that's when the story came back and
i was like but that's those new zealand
filmmakers isn't it they're just like
let's just do it whatever it is
they're they're absolutely amazing you
know i love talking to uh
uh uh
to people that worked on peter's early
films like dead alive or brain dead as
it's known in the rest of the world um
because of just how much
hand to mouth how everyone was doing
everything you know they they talk about
that movie where everyone was covered in
fake blood for weeks on end yeah yeah
and richard tells us when they got
together with peter they would they
would watch all these movies in his
sitting room and he says that pete had
the smallest smallest house in in
wellington
apartment and he had the biggest tv that
you could get in that time and that's
all it was was a tv showing horror
movies
to the the people walking past outside
were just looking in the window at these
three people you know watching these
gruesome horror movies
the the thing about spending that first
day at weta was that like
when you've when you've gone through the
crucible of building stuff for yourself
because you didn't know how to do it any
other way yeah um and you find other
people that have done that you find such
a family because
as richard says the the the the ethos of
new zealand as if it can't be built with
number eight fencing wire it's not worth
building yeah you know i was down there
a couple years ago with a producer of
mine who
uh is latino and she was like why is
that why is that mexican restaurant
called the ass of the world el culo de
monde and i was like because that's what
new zealand calls itself
it's yeah it's brilliant like you can't
get any further away from everywhere
it's just
i mean they're forgotten about on most
world maps right yeah yeah
it's a wonderful country it really is
they're brilliant but let's get back
about again i hear adam so you're in
this you're in this bike shop and and
and you learn you can fix things and
then
you became an actor for a while is that
right well yeah i i i
i'm an extrovert i like performance and
i thought i wanted to be an actor for a
while and i did some commercials i was
in a charming commercial when i was 15.
uh nice stock boy yeah
i was in a billy joel music video where
i was like the best friend who drowns
oh tragic tales
i got hypothermia and got to warm up in
billy joel's trailer nice lovely stuff
he gave me a beer and a cigarette it was
totally appropriate how old were you 15.
lovely perfect
[Laughter]
um and then you know
i didn't know really what i wanted to do
and i i was sort of doing i was doing
auditions but i wasn't really committed
to being an actor and i started to
realize that i was wasting everybody's
time
um that if i was gonna do this i had to
do it or not do it and i realized i was
more interested in making stuff
and so that's where i concentrated and
then i made stuff i was in uh theater
special effects and prop making and
commercial special effects i worked on
movies like ai and star wars episodes
one and two and then in 2002 we made the
pilots for mythbusters
and that's when the performer in me
meets meets the maker
and i get to tie both of these things
together and it's been an amazing
journey you know uh just building stuff
and being able to perform that story and
talk about it but how did mythbusters
how did that come about from making
props well so uh
discovery had this show actually the
show was produced out of sydney by a
company called beyond productions and
they had the idea for a show called
mythbusters but back then
discovery was not a
network that had a lot of talent-based
shows we were one of the earliest ones
right and so they didn't want to invest
in building a shop for this show so they
were looking for somebody who had a shop
already to shoot some pilots and jamie
was somebody they reached out to
and he said he called me up because we
were professional colleagues and he said
look i don't i don't think i could host
a television show on my own but maybe if
you came over and we shot a demo reel
maybe we could do it together
and we shot a demo reel in about two
hours i edited it on my laptop that
night sent it to discovery and they
showed up three weeks later with a
camera crew of only five people just
this tiny little group yeah and we made
three pilots over six weeks
um the show aired about four months
later and they immediately picked up the
first season and then we filmed for 13
years without a break
that is crazy
yeah it's amazing how these what one
little thing
he's got a shop
we're looking for somebody with a shop
because we don't want to build it and
then he gets his mate who he knows is a
bit better at a performer yeah and then
13 years later it's even better than
that because what jamie didn't know when
he called me was that the laptop i
edited on i had bought it specifically
to teach myself the rudiments of
filmmaking
um apple released this laptop in 2002
called the pismo with firewire in and i
bought a little dv camera and i had
spent that spring of 2002 making little
films and then editing them and
storyboarding them and just sort of
understanding how to cut something
together so when he called me i was
perfectly ready because i had a
production studio in my laptop and my
and my camera
you know it's that um that thing of like
chance favor is the prepared mind
oh yeah yeah that i think that's that's
amazing so you like taking apart a bike
you just took apart filmmaking you just
knocked it down into its little parts
and said yeah i can
build this up here yeah well i mean i
i love it when um
again like i know that uh sean asked and
directed a little film in wellington
right i love it when actors
expand and move out and start to look at
this the other aspects because they're
thrilling and making a little film and
editing it was an incredible education
and it taught me that i can edit if i
have to but boy is it not my gene pool
right like that is something that is an
amazing skill that people have and i'm
delighted to know enough about it to
kind of understand the rudiments of it
uh and that's that's what i am i'm a
skill collector i like like gathering
enough of each skill to sort of
understand how it might be useful to me
it can be hard to see the light at the
end of the tunnel when you have high
interest debt and sometimes it can be
even harder to ask for help that's where
upstat comes in
upstart powered personal loans can help
you pay down high interest debt all
online with simple and easy to
understand payment terms upstate has
helped over 1.8 million customers on
their path to financial freedom whether
it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses upstart can
help you get one
fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date
upstarts knows that you're more than
just a credit score so rather than
looking at your credit score alone
upstart's model considers other factors
like your income employment and other
information provided in your loan
application to find you a smarter rate
for your loan
you can check your rate in minutes for
loans between 1 000 to 50 000
without impacting your credit score
don't wait and check your rate today at
upstart.com slash onion that's
upstart.com
onion to check your rate today don't
forget to use our url to let them know
we sent you
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application
go to upstate.com
as you know my body is a temple uh you
know i keep it pretty trim and i like to
go at the gym now i've been drinking
protein shakes and protein powders for
years you jump around to different ones
some of them make you feel a little bit
bloated some of them make you full after
a workout you can never quite work it
out but i finally found a delicious way
to get my protein before and after
workouts and guess what it's magic spoon
now let me give you some steps zero
grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein
and only four net grams of carbs in each
serving only 140 calories a serving the
honey nut flavor has only one gram of
sugar it's keto-friendly gluten-free
grain-free soy-free and low-carb and you
can also build your own box available
flavors to build your very own custom
bundle are cocoa fruity frosted my
favorite peanut butter cookies and cream
maple waffle blueberry cinnamon plus the
newly reformulated honey nut flavor that
will now be added to magic spoons
permanent collection simply because it's
so tasty billy i have it for breakfast
have it pre-workout post-workout and you
know what every so often has a little
lovely guiltless midnight snack so go to
magicspoon.com
to grab a custom bundle of cereal and be
sure to use our promo code onion at
checkout to save five dollars off your
order and magic spoon is so confident in
their product it's packed with a hundred
percent happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for any reason they'll
refund your money no questions ass
remember to get your next delicious bowl
of guilt-free cereal at
magicspoon.com and use the code onion to
save five dollars off thank you magic
spoon for sponsoring this episode
so just before we came on there you were
talking about swords
yes and always a fun thing to have a
sword so one of the skills then that you
have picked up as you were just about to
tell me and i was like adam no this is
good stuff for the podcast just wait
uh it sounds like when you were down in
new zealand that was another skill you
picked up well so on that first day that
i was visiting where i met peter lyon
the swordmaster at wetta who built all
the swords for all the lord of the rings
films
hand ground them
i mean just their amazing work
uh and he showed me sting he showed me
the original sting
and
we came back to san francisco and i
started corresponding with richard i
said i want to come back down i want to
film some stuff and he said what do you
want to film and i said i'd love to
spend a few days learning sword grinding
from peter lyon uh and so we did i came
back and he helped me taught me how to
grind i made aragorn's sword out of
aluminum like a stunt sword right yeah
yeah and
it was so much fun and so
i mean peter's a wonderful teacher but
also just to be in that shop and
grinding this beautiful sword and i went
on to make several more and then a
couple of years ago i reached out to
richard and said i just booked this new
tv show i want to purchase one of
boromir swords because they make
beautiful steel versions
of some of the key lord of the rings
swords and boromirs is my all-time
favorite i just i love the look of that
sword and um
uh yeah those guys actually richard uh
richard actually gifted me bormir's
sword for my birthday that year uh and
presented it to me at comic-con it's one
of my favorite objects in in my
collection
oh it's great and it's impossible to me
that it was ground by a human being it's
per it's absolutely perfect and to like
look at it and realize that like my
friend peter lyon made this is such a
thrill
so as like the steel ones is it is it
basically uh like a rectangle of steel
when you get it yeah exactly
yeah it's a rectangle you draw the sword
on it the first thing you grind is the
fuller the the groove that goes up the
middle then you cut it to size and then
you start to shape it and you you keep
on using sharpie marks and pens to like
make sure your measurements are exact
but then you're sitting there for hours
just passing this sword over ever finer
grades
grits of sandpaper until you've got the
sword you want and and people all over
the world know i'll be wanting an adam
savage sword it'll be like the kill bell
thing
oh he doesn't make them now but you know
i actually have a beautiful replica of
kill bill sword for uh for the bride
[Laughter]
a collector like like like peter jackson
you go to his house and there's just the
weirdest stuff
we discovered when he took me into his
office at wedda which is in you know
behind a secret door and i was like
sitting at his desk we're eating
sandwiches and i see that on his desk is
an enigma machine the cipher machine
from world war ii and i'm like you have
an enigma machine and peter looked at me
and he's like clearly we have the same
pathology
[Laughter]
it's true isn't it
you walk through any of his rooms and
you're like what is this and he's like
oh that's from a 1935 movie and i really
like the problem why wow
it's just i love that yeah we were we
were going through his prop collection
and he had hal 9000 the eye from from
2001 a space odyssey and he showed it to
me and i said um
can i touch this and he said yeah and i
said i think you've got the lens mounted
backwards and i took out the lens and
put it in the other way and showed him
how to light it from the back it's a
story he tells everyone when he shows
that eye eye off that's that's amazing
if it didn't fit back in what would you
have done
i just leave that there i figured
richard would let me borrow a machine
shop and i could you know lathe back the
part that i broke
that's brilliant that's superb
so what what is um so what what would be
the
the perfect day for you in this shop
that you have there well i come in here
uh about five five days a week i come
here every day uh and sometimes i build
small things sometimes i'll do like a
repair
uh
last week i decided i made this this is
the um
electromagnetic pulse button from uh the
matrix oh yeah and i i decided i wanted
one so i did some screenshots and
figured out how it was made and then
slowly built my own over a couple of
weeks
uh
and so like this is this is sort of the
more involved kind of builds i do and
then other things i'll you know i'll
take some small piece that i need to
repair and also film that
um
and then
frankly i'll also often spend a couple
of hours building something off camera
uh like
i i can't do everything on camera i also
like to listen to music and you can't
put on copyrighted music while you're
while you're filming yourself all right
so a lot of the stuff you're doing just
now is for your youtube then yeah yeah
that's most of it i actually
funnily enough uh earlier this year i
did a job for hire i built a spacesuit
for a museum display
i got contacted by this company and uh
you know as an actor you are a
freelancer right you are you are looking
for the work as it's coming in and no
matter how much work there is you're
always wondering what's next uh i'm the
same thing i'm a freelancer my whole
life so this company called me and said
would you build a museum quality
spacesuit for our display and i yeah i
built it over uh april and may and
delivered it and i'm it's on display
down in florida now that's fantastic so
just kind of there just making stuff
whatever whatever comes up that week
i this this space for me it's not very
big um but it's like a swiss army knife
and so for me
it's a very intimate kind of working
arrangement where everything i need is
kind of within my arms grasped uh and so
i can work very very quickly and i
really like
i'm uh
uh i'm an adult i definitely have adhd
attention deficit disorder um and you
know that's the kind of jam that i need
in order to calm down i need i need the
workbench and all my tools at my
disposal
amazing and has that always been the
case when you were growing up did you
always absolutely um
you know
the things that i think that the things
that we do that
we keep on pursuing being excellent at
it
i think we do i do that personally
because
uh i find it very meditative mm-hmm oh
and at this bench this is literally my
main bench that i'm talking to you at
this is where i get to pretend i have
some control over the world which i
don't that's a fiction yeah but here i
do and here i can kind of concentrate
and i can
bring the noise of the world down to
just what's in front of me and what i
need to accomplish right now and i find
that a a very healing
like i've spent my whole life
chasing that like i said chasing that
endorphin rush you think that will
expand didn't you make in your own
movies at some point you know it's funny
the more i know
directors like peter
and you know i know guillermo del toro a
little bit
um
the less i think i want to direct movies
it sounds like such a nightmare
sometimes it sounds like too many
decisions being made and i don't want to
be in charge of all of them i love
making singular things and then
delivering them the idea of what it
would be you know i think of the
because i watched all of the movies i
watched all of the extended cuts of lord
of the rings i watch all the behind the
scenes material and the thing that i
keep on remembering is that shot of them
doing dailies until like 1 32 in the
morning and everybody in the dailies
room is sleeping except there's peter
taking notes and going richard richard
why is this wrong
and i think
i don't know if i'm built for that well
the good thing is you don't need dailies
now when it's digital so what you see is
what you get so straight away you can
take that out adam
and then i think i think you make a
movie
uh in your style
you know i think i mean straight away
saying that you know you look at peter
and you look at guillermo i mean that's
like looking at messi and ronaldo
playing soccer isn't it i mean yeah but
i i feel like i don't know i feel like
you would make great films i would want
to see you i'd like to see a film made
by you and then you've got your style if
you don't want to make all those
decisions you just put
key people in key things and say you
make those decisions you make those um
i'm making a prop right now but it's
going to be a really good one
it's funny i actually i i visited
guillermo on the set of pacific rim and
he walked me through the art department
you know the art department's always
amazing yeah 50 60 people all doing
drawings beautiful intricate things and
i said how do you possibly
how do you possibly delegate to 70
different people
and still maintain a kind of cohesive
vision of the film and guillermo said
you have to give you have to give
everyone total autonomy within a tiny
bandwidth
yeah which is exactly what you're saying
and i i totally appreciate that i i
really do because i love i mean one of
the things i love about going to a place
like is how much everybody in the chain
of making is owning what they're
building and proud of it and in love
with it and having so much fun with it
and it's yeah exactly and it's not uh
it's not a factory it's not like oh
we're putting this out we're putting
that out
like i remember when i was getting my um
gundorian uniform yeah and
the belt on it was sort of
weird it wasn't it didn't go across like
that it was like hold on just a second
hold on just one sec yes right back
he's going
well done that was my doorbell and no
one else was going to answer it who was
at the door adam uh that's my mailman i
i get packed i'm addicted to getting
packages so i get a pack i get packages
every day it's one of my innocent was it
was it what is it something fantastic
something from lost in space here i'll
open it let's see what this is okay do
you like my hat by the way i love your
hat man that is a fantastic cowboy hat
because i was just thinking i don't
think i've ever seen you without a hat
before uh when normally when i meet you
yes no i always yeah the hat is like my
security blanket
well
this wasn't actually a new honor or
anything i just came back from calgary
and they gave me this hat
i just saw it there
well anyway when did you get delivered i
got a bunch of bullets
uh they're fake these are fake bullets
but they're for my um my clint eastwood
gun
belt from from a certain movie uh from
the man with no name you know from a
fistful of dollars
i i found a guy on ebay who makes a
really good replica of clint eastwood's
gun belt but it didn't have bullets so i
bought some bullets from them oh i hope
it fits
let's see
all right so here's the gun belt
um oh it's a nice one oh it's perfect
absolutely look at that you don't even
need to adapt it that's it it's done now
my problem with these is that they're a
little new so i may soak them in
uh some solvent to take off their
coating and then make them a little bit
more like weathered
you know i don't like things to be too
new i want i i interrupted you in the
middle of talking about your gondorian
uniform and i want to hear the rest of
that story yeah because you were just
talking about how you know people get
absolutely you can do whatever you want
and this
little bit that you've got yeah so
obviously someone had got they were to
make the belt the gundorian belt
and it looked absolutely beautiful but
it was like an x
and
so rather than go around and you put
your sword on it
it kind of came up and down
yeah with a bit in the middle sort of
thing so you know up and down like that
yeah and i was like how does this what
would the
and then it suddenly struck me as i was
looking
someone has worked on this for like two
or three months
and you're like oh i
can't accidentally be flipping and
saying i just like one that goes around
please
you know and then
you sort of
you forget that sometimes this
thing that's slightly to the left of
what you would do me like if someone i
could make a belt anyway but if
someone's i'd never think of that
but then when i got it it totally made
the costume something else
it then felt like it came from another
place
that pippin would never have seen and
you know there was then this weird
clothes that he didn't understand so it
informs the character
accidentally and then as you see if it's
worn and you you feel like oh
who where where's this been worn before
and then
in our story you find out it was um
pharaoh
it was his boys he wore it as a boy
so you're it's just all kind of makes
sense if you just let
that person work on that one thing
and do it to the best of their ability
it will accidentally inform the whole
thing you know yeah that's the the
the storytelling that happens all the
way down below the director because
everyone working on every part on the
vam braces and on your gloves and on the
chain mail and on the boots each of
those people is putting story into their
thing and as you you know i gave a toy i
gave a ted talk a few years ago about
how i love cosplay how i love putting on
costumes and i finished it by saying
look every one of us who's putting on
these costumes is putting our bodies
into a narrative that meant something to
us
and we're learning about ourselves in
the process and when i was finished this
movie star came up to me i won't name
him but he came up and he said look i've
never been comfortable with fan culture
and i've never understood why people
wanted to dress up as
characters that i played he said until
now
he said you helped me understand because
this actor was a craftsperson he knew
how costume changed his character he
knew how it informed his performance and
he realized that what we were doing was
was just a little bit adjacent to that
it was a very similar kind of process of
transformation and transmutation
absolutely i i love cosplay and i i feel
like
i feel like over the last 10 15 years
it's taken an even bigger jump now
people it used to be okay um
i'm this character i'm pippin i'm
aragorn from other rings i'm superman
but now they've invented okay i'm
someone else who
lives kind of near them but i have this
going on and i've got that and then they
put their own history into that which in
some ways is even more interesting you
know yeah i know i'll wager when you
when you're like signing autographs at a
con and someone comes up dressed as one
of your characters
that
you can see them having discomfort with
a part of the costume that pissed you
off 15 years ago i'm right
yeah it's so funny they're always
pulling at the neck of the cloak oh god
this thing's just pulling me back the
whole day
that i mean there's a lovely connection
when i see someone else wearing a
costume that i have built and worn i
know that we've chewed on the same mud
together that's great and even better if
they fix it yes i've seen other people
who have like i was like oh does that
not hurt there and they're like oh no i
took this and i i removed that piece and
you're like oh my god you've you've
fixed it
yeah that's even better sean was telling
me a great thing at the weekend that
when we were doing costume for lauder
rings
and they were you know quite early on
and and picking what clothes we would
wear and and all this and and sean said
he found this beautiful he's like oh
it's like a farmer it's a gardener's
cloth but it feels so beautiful and it's
he's like oh this is it
and he said
a week later when he got the costume he
was like this isn't quite the um
cloth that i i fell in love with and
they they came up to you and said ah
yeah
ian mckellen came in after you and he
loved that as well so uh that's now our
that's a gandalf's cloak i'm afraid
yeah fair enough
fair enough what are you going to do
you're going to argue with gandalf no no
you lose that argument yes yeah
so right so mythbusters well i'm not
going to keep you all day sorry adam i
know you get things to take apart and
put back together
but um obviously mythbusters
amazing show and you're probably
recognized all over the world now
because of that show it was just it was
fantastic i love things like that where
it just feels like
somehow it's just caught a moment and
it's just perfect and you know i get
whenever it comes on you just leave it
you know it's just it's it's a perfect
tv show but that's it's no finish right
yeah we wrapped it um
at the end of 2015 after we made 300
hours of the show 285 hours over 13
years you know we didn't you know you
know you've got friends who do tv shows
you do a tv show for eight months and
then you have your off time to go make a
movie um we did mythbusters full-time
year-round for 13 years oh did you
really yeah we had we did three months
on and then two weeks off and then three
months on and two weeks off never more
than two weeks over the whole course of
doing the show oh i didn't know that it
was tiring um but it was also really
like
it was amazing that it showed up and
that
it became a hit so fast
we were figuring out how to do the job
while we were doing it
and then we got to kind of create this
show based on
the enthusiasm of all five hosts you
know we we gravitated towards stories
that interested us yeah and figured out
that the net that
great shows came out of episodes that we
were fascinated by whether or not they
had fire and bombs in them or you know
crazy stunts um
yeah we did 300 hours 13 years uh 85
miles of duct tape
over 2000 explosions for for me and dom
when we talk about this podcast that's
all we always get back to we just want
to talk to people that are passionate
about stuff that that really want to
kind of
do what they're doing and and not have
it as a stepping stone is something else
and and you can always tell and that was
what was so brilliant about that show
was it was just people loving what
they're doing you know
finding out about it as you're finding
out about it being curious it's just
it's just wonderful
well you know like i said discovery
wasn't didn't have a lot of talent-based
shows back in those days and so
like i said we shot the pilots with five
people it was very intimate
um and not only that i was able to have
for me doing the kind of television that
i do having a really good relationship
with my cameraman is really important
uh and i didn't know that because i was
blessed for the first three years with
truly great cameramen and then when i
had cameramen who didn't care as much
about what i was doing i really felt it
and i felt it in the product and i felt
it in what was happening in the in the
relationship between me and the camera
and that really informed also the who we
hired after that and you know the kind
of environment i want on set um but it
was very
it was really lovely to have this sort
of quiet crucible to build the show for
the first couple of seasons with such a
small crew and sort of figure out how we
wanted to make it i i feel so lucky that
we got to make the show we wanted to
make for the whole time we did it
and
how did it feel when it finished i mean
if you're doing it as you say all the
time it's not even as if oh well i know
what it's like not to do it for six
months
you just i mean that must have been the
weirdest feeling i went a little crazy
actually i have a friend who was on one
of the csi shows for six years and she
gave me this great gift i
saw her about a month before we wrapped
and she said oh sweetie you're gonna
lose your mind for a little while
she said you've been doing the same
thing for 14 years you're gonna go a
little nuts without doing it and she was
right and i spent a few months sort of
like i remember at the end of
the first two weeks that we'd wrapped
the show
um i was still getting up every morning
at eight and like running over to the
shop and building stuff and my wife was
like you're still totally manic
and i was like sweetie i don't know any
other way to work than this
and so that first year without doing the
show was spent kind of figuring out how
to live in a different in a different
mode you know
and what did that morph into what was
the next thing well i mean part of it
was
you know when a production takes over
your life
it's hard to get back into your life
and so the time the the last seven years
since we wrap mythbusters have been very
much about
finding a really nice balance between
being home
and coming here and like my wife is a
marriage and family therapist she sees
most of her clients in the afternoons so
my life right now has some very slow
mornings in which we wake up we have
coffee we chat i come over here sometime
around nine or ten it's just it's it's
it's so lovely and
it survived covid you know we we
released seven videos a week through all
of dovid and it was stunning and i'm
moving slightly towards television now
but i'm also really clear how happy i am
coming into my shop and building 40
hours a week
i mean sometimes we forget don't we i'd
i was
off working the last couple of weeks and
i
made a coffee this morning
for me and my wife just like you were
saying and my wife said to me she says
oh i really miss her little chats
just
things that it becomes part of your day
and you don't even think about it that
there's
45 minutes in the morning where we have
a coffee and we just talk rubbish
but you you
you get into that kind of hamster wheel
of
you you're not doing that and those
things are super important
and i think you know and another kind of
modern
times we forget that well and especially
really particularly when you're on a on
a production that is big and
all-encompassing
um it's it's very it took me a long time
to sort of
realize that you know i was at work
doing all these spectacular things all
day long crashing cars and setting off
explosions and when i'm coming home
that's not the most important thing the
most important thing is what's it like
in my house how are things been how are
my kids what was the day like and
slowing down and slotting back into that
you know i ra i one of the things that
we did on mythbusters actually
even though we shot year round because
we shot so constantly we kept very
reasonable hours and i was home by six
six o'clock every night
and so uh you know i never missed dinner
with my kids and for that i'm truly
grateful that we had enough
control over the production that we were
able to do that
yeah i think control's a good word for
it because sometimes when you
you go to tv or film
you you do lose control
i remember watching a thing i think it
was patrick stewart who
he says i was
he must have been on like star trek or
something for a long time
and then his first time going to an
airport
when there's not someone leading him
through the airport and taking his
ticket and he just felt like what do i
do in this building you know i'm stuck
in this
that you do lose control yeah people say
you're getting picked up tomorrow at 4am
you're having lunch here you're doing
that and
it's quite easy to sort of okay take the
control you know and i've found later i
try and keep as much even if it's little
things like
i'll rent a car and i'll take myself
there rather than just always be
you're getting picked up you're getting
drunk you know sometimes it's nice just
to hold whatever control you you can so
it's great to hear that you guys
uh had the the mind foresight to know
that if you're going to do something for
a long time like that you you have to
have that control you have to pace
yourself and you know
when you do have a hit show
you end up with this weird kind of power
where you could call your boss's boss's
boss
and complain but you don't want to use
that power
nearly at all unless it's crazy
important and jamie and i and kerry and
grant and tori we were all really clear
that the only thing we wanted to do with
the power was make our shooting schedule
a little easier
so by the end of making mythbusters we
had something like 12 days to shoot
every single episode
and i mean that's a lux you know normal
televisions like seven days for a whole
hour of television we had 12 13 days it
was luxurious and we were never gonna
get that again you know it's like yeah
no this is this is the dream and that's
all that we did with our power we you
know we only did it to extend our
schedule so are you feeling now after
after that that you are ready to do
another tv or
i do you look you know i started
mythbusters when i was in my 30s i'm in
my middle 50s now
um i can no longer build something
spectacular every single week on
television i don't have the stamina i
won't hold up
um
so fundamentally the kind of television
i want to make is a little bit different
but
i love telling stories i love
making things accessible to people by
giving them a physical understanding of
something they didn't know that they
could understand
yeah i love
communicating about the world in a way
where you go
oh wow
and that that gasp there's a great david
mamet quote in which he says in theater
it's easy to blackmail the audience into
a standing ovation but you can never
blackmail them into a gasp ah
lovely
and i'm sure you've had the experience
of being on stage when the audience did
that
and there's there's nothing like that
feeling you're all sharing something
really special at that moment and there
was a lot of those on miss buster's
yeah it was fabulous sometimes you guys
would be gasping it was great
but what but what's that going to be
though what's what's your next thing
then i mean is it is it travel traveling
the world and looking at things being
built
how did people build that well you know
at each stage in your life you kind of
come up with a i like to come up with a
north star of the way i'd like things to
be and right now i'll tell you and this
may sound like i'm putting on the
biggest heirs imaginable but one of my
heroes is david attenborough and i would
love to
approach being the david attenborough of
engineering helping people understand
engineering in all of its incredible uh
facets in the same way that david
attenborough helps us understand our
planet and our world and nature in all
of its incredible facets and i've been
watching him since i was 10 years old uh
and
when i have done television that i think
i'm most proud of it has been that i am
using my enthusiasm to show the audience
the mysteries that have been revealed to
me that hopefully i'm revealing to them
uh so that's that's the the broad rubric
of the kind of television i'd like to
make
what that ends up being i'm not sure
that's yeah i'm in i you've sold me that
sounds fantastic
i want to watch you every week take
apart a machine and tell me why they did
it and how they did it absolutely adam
that'd be brilliant and in the meantime
make that movie
uh can i be in it and i'd like some
fantastic props you're in you're done
i'm you're i'm putting you on the list
let's totally do it i don't i don't want
to keep you any longer um i i know uh
i've made you talk too much but
fantastic
what a great sort of insight into your
incredibly interesting life we'd love to
get you back on when when don can be
here if that's all right any time any
time you call i'm i'm here man it's been
such a pleasure billy and so much fun
seeing you at all those cons last year i
hope to run into it one this year again
i'm sure we will and if you could build
me a guitar that would be lovely
from a tree and some
cats tales absolutely absolutely man
absolutely wonderful thank you very much
adam oh and where can people make sure
that people can see your show just now
oh yeah yeah so my youtube channel is
tested t-e-s-t-e-d
um i'm also the real adam savage on
instagram and uh don't try this on
twitter
lovely stuff yeah go i mean everybody
knows who you are anyway so it's not
like i'm introducing someone but please
let's always keep watching adam and what
he's up to thank you very much mate
thank you
thank you so much my friend a pleasure
well don what'd you think about that i
mean fantastic right incredible we
missed you though i know yeah i really
did i remember i thought i was hoping
that you'd make it but it was the only
time we could get adam and we didn't
want to lose him because he's such an
interesting man great man and obviously
working from a place of passion exactly
which is what we love on this show yeah
and built his whole thing around that
you know that that space that he's
working from is just
so
amazing and obviously has
now got that amazing relationship with
the people at weta
so um and you can tell how they would
hit it off you know just the same
headspace of let's make these brilliant
things how does this work and you know i
know what i would have asked what's
going on
i can't understand this but it happens
all the time right what do we hear this
do you take let's say a bathroom tap
right here in the united states faucet a
5k take a faucet
right so take a tap right right
and turn it on
just so it's dripping virtually nothing
but virtually nothing just a just a tiny
little drip not like a drip every minute
but it looks like a drip yeah
right like that and it's not going to
change from the drip it's not going to
suddenly create a stream it's always
going to drip right
take your finger
and put it underneath the drips so it's
not connecting to the drop at the top
it's connecting to the drip that has
fallen from the top bit yeah yeah sooner
or later that drip will turn into a
stream
why does that happen
does it really yeah i'll show you the
next time i'm at your house i used to do
it all the time when i was a kid and i
was like what is that about so it's drip
drip drip
you put your finger under and there's
some
some
chemical changes is your finger touching
the tap no no
independently just hitting one of the
drips that's falling from the stop above
and sooner or later
it forms a stream
i can't explain it myself i don't even
know if adam could or maybe even albert
einstein drip drip drip the drip drip
drip finger under stream yeah would it
work if you had
a faulty prostrate
possibly have you got one could you try
it i think i'm all right
i don't understand that but if there's
anyone out there that knows why that
happens or if it's indeed happened to
you or maybe you can try it at home and
get back to us let us
know and let us know at the friendship
onion at cassmedia.com
or leave us a voicemail at
speakpipe.com
forward slash the friendship onion yes
and you can also leave questions
comments and concerns yes on our youtube
channel which is the french bunny
podcast obviously and then um if you can
rate and review and subscribers it means
we can make more and more episodes which
we like doing
and uh it'll make us happy get your
friends to subscribe do all of that
anyway that was a really fun one dom
wasn't it i didn't enjoy it i did enjoy
it but i wish you had been there well
i'll never leave you again
guys we'll see you next week see you
next week on a friendship onion no
turtles
harmonize with me and hold
[Music]
the baby you're my pearl